talk about the president's visit
um he has been giving speeches he's made
that secret visit to Ukraine but today
he's meeting a group of Nations known as
the Bucharest nine which as you pointed
out earlier quite a lot of people would
have heard of as a group before
explaining their significance and what
was being discussed today yes it was
formed in in 2015 by Poland and Romania
because of the Russian invasion of
Crimea the Caesar of Crimea and it was
the border states and it's a good
grouping and given that the American
president was there it makes sense to
have another declaration to strengthen
the more declarations you can have the
better because they all say essentially
the same thing behind that is the fact
that this goes from north to south and
it brings out the fact that the northern
members of NATO or whatever it is in
Europe they have a slightly different
agenda the northern members worry about
Russia they worry about the North
Atlantic the southern members tend to
worry about illegal migration Economic
Development what's happening in the
western Balkans which looks as if it
might blow up again and so their agendas
are different holding them together is
easy in a big declaration but behind
that declaration I think there will be
some tensions which we may hear about in
the next week or two and talking about
countries and their own agendas can we
talk about how
come different countries support for
Ukraine has changed or not over the
course of this year very good point this
was the general assembly on the 2nd of
March last year so immediately after the
invasion of Ukraine the general assembly
held introduced the resolution really
strong it deplored The Invasion and
demanded demanded that Russia withdraw
immediately and 100 that was the result
141 States voted in favor five states
voted against that was Russia and
Belarus North Korea Syria and Eritrea so
they were the five holdouts but 35
States abstained and so if you put those
together 35 Plus 5 is 40 it was 141 to
40. that's pretty decisive but those 40
States actually involved more than half
of the world's population and when we
looked at that as analysts we said okay
it'll be interesting to see how that
changes over the months a year later no
change
no change quite remarkable isn't it and
of course all those countries have
different reasons for that as we said
their own agendas hedging their bets as
to who may come out
um in front in this war and can we talk
about Latin America because it's the
ripple effect of War isn't it all
International diplomatic decisions have
an effect and as far away as Brazil you
know Latin America decisions being made
here have an effect on Ukraine now the
global South yep and you say well that's
in America surely everyone assumes that
America dominates Latin America Latin
Americans follow what America's
numerically not at all a lot of the
Latin American countries have weapons
that are either ex-soviet weapons or
weapons that the ukrainians could use so
there's quite a lot of weapons in Latin
America which should be really useful in
Ukraine America made a really generous
offer to Latin American states they said
if you transfer your weapons to Ukraine
we will replace them one for one with
modern American weapons none of them
agreed none and so they hold out I mean
Mexico didn't agree the three big
important States Mexico Brazil still
Argentina none of them agreed Colombia
didn't agree Ecuador didn't agree a flat
no to a really generous offer they said
no neutrality the only state that's gone
along with a bit of it is chilly and
Chile has offered some demanding
equipment I mean not exactly important
and interestingly public opinion in
Latin America is behind that view public
opinion in Latin America is neutral they
want to stay neutral and the point is
any Diplomat will tell you being neutral
in this war means that you don't mind if
the Russians win because any peace talks
any ceasefire means that the Russians
will keep whatever they've conquered
that's the way it is so countries that
opt for neutrality are not saying they
want the Russians to win but they what
they're saying is Well we don't really
mind if they do and that's the problem
that President Biden has he goes to
Poland he makes a ringing endorsement
but the global South kind of shrugged
its shoulders and says we don't really
believe this is about democracy and
freedom and rule of law we think this is
just another War yeah not our war not
our war specifically and with regards to
the weapons obviously the weapons that
um Latin America will have you said a
older model so low Tech and the reason
they would work in Ukraine is because
presumably it's the kind of equipment
that Ukraine has already would take very
little training you know they're asking
for leopard teachers we keep hearing
don't we also 272 times maintenance lots
of artillery ammunition and you know
nobody in Latin America needs any
military force most of them are sort of
the vanity projects or their leaders I
mean Latin America is a very peaceful
continent now that the the the the farc
um War is Over in Colombia the whole of
Latin America is at peace okay lots of
tensions but no war yeah lots of
tensions and presumably obviously
America's offer is we will replace you
know those weapons for new weapons but
again that's not going to be very good
for Latin America because again it comes
down to training maintenance and America
presumably aren't offering that yeah no
but it was a very generous offer I mean
who wouldn't want to get rid of their
old stuff and get modern American stuff
in its place and it was it was a test it
was also a test of loyalty and you know
and you know the anti-americans always
assume that America somehow has a sort
of post-colonial grip on Latin America
not a bit of it not a bit of it I mean
the United States has surprisingly
little influence in Latin America what
the you know where people used to think
they dominated they really don't and of
course there are some real hold out
States so Venezuela Nicaragua Cuba those
are left-wing dictatorships who won't
touch America with anything you you
don't expect any change out of them for
anything the Americans say but Mexico oh
Brazil Argentina those are the big three
if they go along with something the
others will and they wouldn't go along
with this